[Music]
please welcome pretty lights
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
the conan o'brien audience how y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll be your host for the pretty lights
extravaganza
yo right now it's the best moment to
ever know
[Music]
is
[Music]
come on
[Music]
feel good
[Music]
yo
right now is the best moment you ever
know
right now it's the best moment
[Music]
that's right
[Music]
high my city is like requirement my
environment i won't harp in it like a
violin and a lot back in the house like
the santa fe puts it up like a fan on
the block hand to god what is hard right
now it's the best moment you ever know
you gotta make it your own let's take it
home yeah you gotta make it to only take
a whole year you gotta make it your own
take
[Music]
[Music]
if you do it for the love of it
hands up if you do it for the love of it
[Music]
wait a minute
know
[Music]
come on
yeah
yeah that's right
[Applause]
[Music]
everything everything is
[Music]
great thank you so much
that was great that's fantastic there's
something pretty lights tell him we'll
take a break